taking the books back so what you try to
do here you're trying to make me feel
bad when in actuality you're the one
that missed the payments
but we've been trying to get you the
money but it's been so difficult to
raise the funding the children are
sponsoring another bake sale next month
so let's your tell you that that there
is your problem
look you can't expect the bake sale to
make solid cash these days you got these
these places you got what
Cinnabon you got Dunkin Donuts Starbucks
they all they will make their own baked
goods you guys do you really gotta start
thinking outside the box you see what
I'm trying to say you miss a sister but
the children love the books
thank you I mean I know that I made them
and you know I'm the one that ran the
focus groups but I like hearing that
mr. Hobbs your two o'clock is here
would you please use the intercom we
talked about this
do you want me use it now because I
already already told you
are you second
yeah
mr. Hobbs your two o'clock is here too
okay got it
well I'll tell you what yeah I know how
much these books mean to your kids over
there so it's Christmas and what the
hell I'm gonna well I'm gonna give you a
three-week extension Oh looks your heart
Leo's as well